we have a daughter with a life limiting
a lot of shortening condition and we
have some brilliant experts and they'll
be in work to the Bone
you know and actually
the level of care they provide is
amazing but they're not being able to
provide it in the way they want to
provide it because the resourcing's not
there and the number of people coming
through the door is too many and it's
not fair to blame it on the pandemic
anymore is it because actually we have
problems in the NHS before we went into
the pandemic we were short of doctors we
were short of feds going into the
pandemic so I think it's really wrong to
blame it on the pandemic and actually
the damage that you're doing to to
families like myself is terrible so
until you as a government prioritize
part of social care
We're Not Gonna free up then they're
already limited number okay I am so
scared about my daughter's future
thinking about what you guys might do
for the NHS and what that means any
exact terms for the length of her life